another yarn
cutie
put your tongue up
okay it's okay
[Music]
enjoying support for Daddy's teams
[Applause]
it's been sitting look at this
look at you go there we go
[Music]
to camera
oh there we go
one year went by so fast
[Music]
is that Luca
so today is a very exciting day it's
Luca's first birthday party so today is
January 28th his birthday is not until
Tuesday the 31st but we're celebrating
today and it this has been like the most
fun project I've ever met ever but the
most fun project I've done recently I
think I first started planning it maybe
about three months ago but I didn't
really like start doing things for it
until maybe like a few months ago that
would be big but yeah I'm so excited
because like I said I've been working on
this party for a couple months now and
I'm so so so excited to see my vision
come to life I fully learned Photoshop
for this party because I I photoshopped
all of the artwork that you'll be seeing
I I did so much and I'm just so excited
here's the birthday boy nice and excited
for his day he doesn't even know what's
going on I got a photographer too to
come and take pictures today so we're
gonna have nice photos to remember the
day right now the people outside are
like the tent people who the tent girl
she's also doing the backdrop and she
brought tables and chairs so she's like
kind of like a One-Stop shop I also got
some soft play area slash also a bouncer
and then I already showered so I look
the way I do yeah what's next Luca what
are we gonna do oh I also used our
furniture from the house so look at our
bedroom I use the TV console for the
dessert table so our bedrooms look like
this for about a week now because I did
this about a week ago and I was like
planning out how we're gonna lay out all
the desserts his cake came out so cute
and in case he's out running a whole
bunch of errands
we picked up generator and I'm gonna go
and pick up uh some Don tots because we
want some Don tots to represent my
Chinese culture and then we also have
tacos catered as well as churros so
we're trying to represent our cultures
here for Lucas first birthday party so
it's your cultures what do your cultures
Chinese and Mexican
hi yeah I'm just trying to like plan out
his naps too this party's only for four
hours so I'm like okay if I plan out if
I time everything out right he should be
able to stay awake for the whole party I
mean you know he might get a little bit
tired towards the end but yeah
[Music]
Clap by the way this week whatever
yay you're excited huh my cutie look at
that smile
yay
Bravo
[Music]
this came out so good how cute I love it
thank you guys you're so sweet thank you
for helping me okay this is so funny
I've been running around with half of my
hair done because so many people came
and Christina came Gary's here to do my
hair and then doreen's here for the
charcuterie table I'm not just doing a
whole bunch of stuff
so fun I love this feeling of like
getting stuff done like the hecticness
and I don't know it's really fun
[Music]
okay so this boy has been asleep for
half his party
was eating just now
are you ready to go to your party now
everyone's waiting for you
[Music]
I literally painted all these plates wow
oh
hi you blowing kisses does it get closer
moment
his brother has the same one
[Music]
thank you
my Base today
[Music]
happy birthday Lucas
foreign
[Music]
here we go happy birthday to you happy
birthday to you
happy birthday
happy birthday to you yay
[Applause]
[Music]
PewDiePie
oh yeah
there's a piece right here that's good
the rest of it's on the ground
[Music]
oh my gosh
oh my goodness
I don't know
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]